Hi, everyone. Welcome to the closing webinar of
the "Imaging Science" series. So, we're
about to get started.
We have lots of cool images from
researchers to show you and the ones
that you all have sent in, as well. So,
just scroll through a selection of those.
With that, I'm going to hand this
over to Erika Reinfeld, who's going
to start us off.
[Erika] Thank you so much, Brian. All right.
We are so excited to be here
with you. So, two weeks ago, we hosted the
opening webinar. I am actually not
looking at the poll, so I don't know how
many of you attended it. If you didn't, I
hope you'll log on to the museum site
and check it out.
We hosted that with two fabulous
photographers, Keith Ellenbogen and
Felice Frankel, and we are really excited
to close this week out with the research
counterpart to that. So, our researchers,
our guests researchers, will be sharing a
couple of their own science photographs
with you. Images that came out of active
research here at MIT. And then they'll be
talking to you about some of the images
that they saw on this two-week
exploration that they found really
intriguing. Before we jump into their
presentations, I did want to call out a
couple of the themes from the
opening webinar by contact for context
for this conversation. So, one of the
central ideas that we talked about was
the idea of photography and imaging as a
tool of science; helping us to make
observations and to communicate
scientific ideas. As science
photographers, both Keith and Felice
notice science everywhere. But, I thought
it was really interesting that Keith
identifies as an artist, Felice does not.
So, they both talked about the
intentionality of a "good" science
photograph and that an important
element of that is being intentional
about your photography, but also leaving
yourself open to discovery. I think
that's very characteristic of a lot of
the images we're going to be looking at
today. One of the comments that came
through in the chat that I really liked,
was that many of the photographs that we
saw were, in some ways, unintentional art;
they weren't designed to be art, but they
still had an artistic component to it. It
was a combination of the
expected and the unexpected that come
together to tell the story. We also
talked a little bit about maintaining
the scientific integrity of a photograph...
of the scientific subject... when taking a
photograph, but then still using the
photograph to tell a story. Then
finally, we talked a little bit about the
value of bringing both people and ideas
together to create a photograph and make
sense of what's being represented in the
world. So, [clap] in that spirit, we're going to
bring in our guests. As they present
their images, you are welcome to use the
Q&A feature, down at the bottom of your
screen, to address questions, either to an
individual or to the whole group, and
we'll try to get to, at least a handful
of those, after everyone has presented
their image. So, we're going to start with
Sudha Kumari, who is a researcher at the
Koch Institute, where I work. You can see
the public galleries behind me. This is
our annual Image Awards exhibition of
biomechanical images. I actually use
Sudha's winning image from the Image
Awards often to represent the
Image Awards competition as a whole and
just as an example of a scientific
photograph. So, I'll stop talking and let
Sudha tell you and show you more.
[Sudha] Hi, everyone. So, I am Sudha Kumari. I hope
you are able to hear me and hope you're
having a wonderful weekend. So, I am a
research scientist at the Irvine Lab
here at the Koch Institute of
Integrative Cancer Research. In the
Irvine Lab, we believe that our immune
system is a powerful agent to fight
diseases -- different types of diseases
like cancer and autoimmune diseases. And
we also believe that when cancer
develops, there's a compromised function
of immune systems... somehow immune system
is suppressed and that's how cancer
progresses. If we can actually clip
the immune cells, or the cells' immune
system, to fight back at the cancer,
we can actually tackle cancer eventually.
So, what I'm going to share with you
today is actually image, which is
actually a summarized story of my
project that shows many different
subplots in a single image. As to which
immune cells I'm using and how they're
interacting with the immune cells, or
with the cancer cells, and how what we
hope to achieve using this interaction.
So, I'll just briefly, in a brief moment, I
will share my image with you guys.
Yeah. So, basically, my project started
with trying to see how the immune cells,
(specifically the t-cells, which might
threaten immune cells because they can
directly recognize and kill cancer cells)
how they interact, how they communicate
how they talk to the cancer cells, and
are they able to actually kill cancer
cells? So, I took cancer cells, which are
large cells shown here -- these are cancer
cells here -- in a dish and I threw some
t-cells that would actually recognize
and kill the tumor cells and then let
them interact. It was a very
interesting interaction to watch because
I could see the t-cells were
actually attacking the tumor cells. I
had already loaded the t-cells with
nanoparticles that have drug that would
increase t-cell function.
They'll increase the capability to fight
these tumor cells. I could see that
the drug-loaded t-cells were beautifully
binding to the tumor cells. So, they were
recognizing them and they were able to
actually kill tumor cells. So, in the
image, the two different tumor cells -- the
one that is healthy, and the other one,
which is sort of retracting, which is a
sign of it being killed by the t-cells.
So, in this image, you could actually see
different part of the processes that
entail my project, which is looking at
the interaction of immune cells, such as
t-cells, or the tumor cells, as well as
seeing how drug-loaded nanoparticles
could help t-cells in their ability to
kill tumor cells. The idea was that
if you can actually see this process in
a dish, hopefully we'll be able to
recapitulate it in the body sometime, in
the models of cancer, and be able to take
care of disease progression in the real
situation. So, with that, I'd like to thank
you for your attention and give
it back to Erika. Thank you.
[Erika] Thank you so much, Sudha. One of the
things I love about this image is that
it tells a very dramatic science story.
It's a very "good versus evil" battle.
But it also, is an image that really
comes out of the scientific process. Did
this experiment that we were doing
actually work?
So, our next image that we're going to
look at, is also an image of documenting
a scientific process and it's really
looking at the experiment a little more.
So, I think Matt, if you would like to get
your image all queued up, I'll turn it
over to Matt Victor.
[Matt] Thanks, Erika. Just give me one second to
share my image.
So, my name is Matt Victor.
I am an HHMI Hanna Gray Fellow at the
Picower Institute for Learning and
Memory. I have a PhD in neuroscience,
but a lot of the questions I'm interested
in have to do with the developing brain.
The approach I take is that I model
neuronal development, or brain
development, with stem cells. The field of
stem cell has really exploded in the
past decade when the discovery was made
that a fully differentiated adult cell,
for example a skin cell, could be
reprogrammed to become a stem cell and
that stem cell can then be made into all
known cell types in our body. That's
what we call induced pluripotent stem
cells or iPSCs. So, I work with iPSCs
and I differentiate the stem cells to
become neurons, which are brain cells.
Neurons have this amazing capacity to
generate electrical signaling and that's
how information is processed in our
brain. So, what I'm showing you here, is an
image of nearly 20,000 neurons. The cell
bodies are kind of white circles, but
these cells, they have a very unique
morphology where they protrude
extensions to make connections between
different cells. So, you can see in here,
it's a droplet of 20,000 cells that have
been allowed to grow and they were
plated on a multi electrode array. So,
these larger black dots that are
connected wires, are actually reading the
electrical potentials that the cells are
generating. I'm using the cells as a
proxy for a developing brain cell
to understand how activity shapes their
maturation. So, as we develop, we receive
a lot of input, for example sensory input,
like your mother's touch, and all those
sensory inputs are transformed into
activity that's processed by the brain.
There is reason to think that that's
a very important part of developing a
mature brain. So, we're trying to mimic
that in the dish. So, I think this
image is striking because it conveys a
very difficult technique, which is
generating these cells from stem cells
and getting them to be functional, but it
also tells you a little bit about the
interconnectivity of the cells -- you
can see this meshes are connected -- and
some of the readouts of my research,
which is to study how electrical
activity changes with maturation in
vitro. So, I'll stop here and chat more later,
if you have more questions.
[Erika] Thank you so much, Matt. Yeah. When Matt submitted this to the Image Awards contest, he also
submitted an image that was just the
neurons and it was a beautifully
striking image -- these glowing cell bodies,
and all these interactions, and data that
Matt was talking about. But, the judges
chose this image because they loved how
it documented the process of observing,
as well. And one of the things I talked
about in the opening webinar was making
comparisons across different scales of
science. And so, with that, we're actually
going to move onto another image that
also has a combination of the thing
doing the observing, and the thing
being observed. So, Calvin Leung
is going to show his image.
[Calvin] Yeah. Thanks, Erika. Hi, everyone. My name
is Calvin. I am a PhD candidate and a
member of the CHIME – FRB
collaboration. So, as you might guess, I'm
an astrophysicist and one of my biggest
science goals is to survey the night sky
for these mysterious objects called,
"Faster Radio Bursts." These are
brief, bright radio flashes that are
coming from all directions towards Earth
and we think they come from outside the
Milky Way galaxy. So, they're
fascinating because they're just
milliseconds long, but in that one
millisecond or so that they turn on, they
can sometimes outshine their entire
host galaxy. So, this makes them
extremely powerful, but super mysterious
objects to detect, because they just come
and go and you never see them again. So,
this is a picture of the Canadian
Hydrogen Mapping Intensity Experiment, or
CHIME, and what we do, is we have these four cylinders, which are shaped
like so because they have an enormous
field of view of the sky, unlike your
regular telescope, which just stares in a
tiny, little patch of sky. So, for
reference, your conventional telescope,
that you might see, you know, on the
mountaintops of Mauna Kea or at
Palomar Observatory, might have a field
of view of about a 60th of a degree by a
60th to the degree. But, with our radio
telescope, with its metal
structure, you know, with these
cylinders, which are each 20 meters
wide and 80 meters long, and the way they
point at the sky, they can actually
survey a two-degree wide strip of the
entire night sky, running north-south. So, we have this massive barcode scanner
on the sky, that surveys different
parts of the sky as the Earth
rotates beneath it. So, this unique
design has allowed us to discover more
fast radio bursts in a year than have
ever been detected in the past decade.
So, this has really transformed the
field and so I wanted to include a
picture of, not just the night sky that
we're so fascinated by, but also the
unique instrument
that lets us perform these
transformative observations. So,
that's sort of the science side of this
picture. On the aesthetic side, one
of the things I really liked about it is
that it conveys a strong sense of
purpose. You see these, like, massive
metal cylinder structures and there's
obviously some purpose to it. Their
irregularity,
you know, gives us a sense of, like,
unity and harmony that I think... that really sends chills down my
spine, even though I think about this
experiment every day. Also, I think, on
a more personal note, I mean, I really
like this image because it, you know,
because I am, as a scientist, I'm
really interested in instrumentation, and
the development of new instruments,
that can allow us to make
transformative new science observations,
like the unique design of our
cylindrical telescope. And so, to me,
every time you do astrophysics, it's a
sort of, communion between the telescope
and the night sky. So, I think this is
just a particularly complete way of
expressing that. It's not just the sky,
but it's also what you use to look at it.
And so, you know, in summary, those
three things -- sort of the science
appeal, the sense of grandeur
that you get, and also that sort of
personal touch make, you know, make me
have this feeling that something
magical is really going on
here. That's why I showed this photo.
Before I finish, I want to just
mention that I actually did not take
this. This was taken by one of my very
close collaborators, Andre Renard, at the
University of Toronto. That's all I've
got.
I'll pass it back to Erika. Thank you.
[Erika] Thank you so much, Calvin. Yeah. One of the things I think is really interesting -- so it's a
photo of nature, it's a photo of
technology, but somehow, when you put all
those things together, it's also a very
human photo about our own mission to
understand the world and to learn more
about the world and create things that
help us appreciate what's going on in
nature. So, with that, I think we're going to
shift gears to some
different engineered cylinders. We're
going to head back to the biological scale
and look at the image of something
that we built to, not just
understand how the body works, but also
to improve how the body works.
Quinton Smith is our next presenter.
[Quinton] All right. Good afternoon, everyone and thank
you so much for joining today.
My name is Quinton Smith. I'm a
postdoctoral fellow at MIT's Koch
Institute and I work under the
mentorship of Sangeeta Bhatia's
laboratory for multi scale regenerative
technologies. So, the particular research
lens that I'm focused in, is liver tissue
engineering. So, the liver is one of
the coolest organs. It actually has a
unique ability to regenerate. You can
actually remove two-thirds of the liver
and it will completely regrow.
So, we've actually taken advantage of
that unique property for people who
actually need liver transplants for
survival. So, you can do something called
a split liver transplant, where you can take
a liver from one person and put it in
another and it can actually grow back on
both of the patients. So, one of the big
difficulties within this field is that
there is over 114 thousand people in the
United States that are in need of this
life-saving surgery. So, there's not
enough donors to support this demand. So,
I'm actually a chemical engineer by
training. So, you kind of think about how
can we create engineering solutions
to really bridge the gap between the
unavailability of these organ systems.
So, in this one here... this image
here, I want to demonstrate one
particular architecture within the liver
as a way to create miniature livers
in the lab that we can actually implant
for patients. So, there's like, kind of a
lot of different intricacies that were
done to really create this picture. So,
what I'm showing here, is an image of
something called a "biliary duct." So, this
is a very important component within the
liver, that's actually responsible for
carrying bile acid from the liver to the
small intestines, where it actually helps
in, aids in, digestion. So, people who
have liver problems, for example, they
actually get something called jaundice,
where you have yellowing of the eyes, or
yellowing of the skin and nails, and this
is actually that bile acid leaking out.
So, we understand this biliary
architecture is very important. So, what
I'm showing in this image here, are cells
that make up the bile duct where we can
control their architecture in a very
specific manner. So, this open structure
that we can create is actually on the
order of a human hair size. So, these are
around 150 to 300 microns in diameter.
And how we do it -- we use a pretty cool
technique. We use acupuncture needles and
we cast a biologically relevant material
in which cells thrive in and use the
acupuncture needles as a sacrificial
mold. After we create this mold with the
extracellular matrix that builds up
tissues, we can remove this really small
needle and we're open with perfusable
systems, where we can seed with these
biliary epithelial cells. So, what I
really like about this image, is that we
can see that, as engineers, that
we can recapitulate the architecture
that we see in biology. So, here's a proof
of concept where we can create these
very two standing structures that mimic
the architecture of the liver itself. So,
I really like this picture and I hope
you guys do and I'm really excited for
the Q&A session afterwards. And, with that,
I'll give it back to Erika. Thank you.
[Erika]
Thank you, Quinton. Yeah. I actually
learned about, like many of the Image
Awards entries, I learned about this
project, before I saw the image, and I made
Quinton draw me lots of pictures of how
it all worked. And then seeing this image,
just really Illustrated, you know, how
important the photography was for
understanding these sorts of things. So,
our final image today is actually not an
image that was taken through research,
but is really an image taken of research.
So, Lina Colucci is going to share the
final image before we move into Q&A.
[Lina] Hi, everyone. My name is Lina Colucci. I have
a PhD from MIT and Harvard Medical
School. I
wrapped that up a couple years ago and,
since then, I actually co-founded a
boutique data science consulting company
called Edge Analytics. We're out in the
Bay Area and, basically, companies bring
us in to help us solve their really
difficult machine learning challenges.
We work with big Fortune 500 companies,
we work with some of Silicon Valley's
top startups, and we're with them from
early prototyping of potential solutions,
de-risking, all the way to, ultimately,
building and shipping the best ones.
The photo that I'm going to share with
you today is one that has a really
interesting backstory. So, this is... I'm
gonna get into exactly what you're
looking at in a second. Essentially
one of my lab mates at MIT asked me to
help her photograph her PhD research.
She works on novel cancer treatments and
essentially she developed these
materials that are filled with cancer-treating drugs in them. Essentially,
you implant these materials into the
body and they slowly release these
cancer-treating drugs and provide the
person's chemotherapy in a long-term way.
The goal, however, is that you want to
insert these implants to treat someone's
cancer in as a minimal type of surgery as
possible. So, you don't want to have a big
surgery. So, she came up with the idea of
creating these implants and folding them
like origami. So that this material
can fold up really small and through
something called a laparoscopic surgery, you can insert this material through
very tiny incision. But then once it's
actually inside the body, the material
opens up and can spread through a larger
of the body and treat a big area of the
body. In this case, it would be the
abdomen. So, when she came and asked me to
help her photograph these implants, it was a little bit challenging
because the ink lines are white, or
transparent, so they don't necessarily
photograph well. So, the interesting
backstory is, we came up with the idea
actually using origami paper itself and
then playing around with lights to kind
of help create these interesting shadows
and coloring effects of these implants.
So, here you can see some of the behind-the-scenes photos that we took in
creating this image. So, playing around
with squeezing the implants, different
shapes, lighting origami paper in the
background. And what you can see is the
different variety and types of images
that we were able to take through these
techniques. This is an interesting video
we took at the end that really kind of
shows the beauty of these origami folds.
Really, the clever part of her work
is using this really ancient art form of
origami to a new type of cancer
treatment, something that can help people
in the modern world today. So, with that, I
will pass it back to Erika.
[Erika] Thank you,
Lina. Yeah. We wanted to close with, close
the sharing with that, in part, because
Lina did such a great job of explaining,
kind of, the choices that she made in
taking these images. Even though this
was, kind of, a macroscale device, I think
all the images that we are looking at
today, there were choices made in how to
set it up and present it. That ties
really nicely into this first question
that we've gotten on the Q&A. So, again,
I'm going to remind everybody that the
Q&A window is open. So, please submit your
photos whether for... your questions sorry,
for an individual or the group. But, we're
going to bring everybody back on screen now
and our anonymous attendee would like to
know... Oh and let me note that this
presentation is being recorded. You
probably saw it at the top of your
screen, but we are recording it and we'll
be posting this online with the other
"Imaging Science" tutorials and the
opening webinar. But, the question on
screen here is, "What advice would you
give to other researchers or people
trying out science photography about how
to make their images more compelling?" And
anyone can take it. We're going to try the
free-for-all and see how it goes.
[Quinton]
So, I think one important thing, just with
scientific imaging, is there are a lot of
different tools that you can use, but I
really think the narrative behind the
stories really brings it home. So, just
from the other panelists, I was very
impressed about your storytelling
abilities and I think really having that
background on that story
really elevates the meaning of those
pictures. So, for me, for example, when I
show my friends pictures of cells,
they're like, "I don't understand what
this is." But when you put it, when you
contextualize it, I think that really
elevates the importance of the picture.
[Matt] I
will add my own thoughts on it. But one
of my advisors, at some point, told me
that I was trying to make my images too
pretty. And I think, kind of, appreciating
the inherit noise, and complexity, and
maybe ugly parts of biology (and by
ugly, I just mean not uniform, not, you
know, so tight) kind of appreciating
that's there's beauty in that, as well. I
think that goes a long way.
[Lina] I guess I'll just add some thoughts from purely, you know, a photographic
perspective. I totally agree with the
narrative and what Quentin and Matt
have said. From purely photographic
perspective, it only helps to have a
really high-quality photo. Right. So, what
that means is, things in focus, really
nice composition, lighting, crops. Like,
that having a beautiful, you know, it doesn't
have to be beautiful in the "nice-looking"
way, but a nicely composed photo
with good technique, is what's going to make
someone pause and be like, "Oh wow! That's
really interesting. What is that?" So,
good photographic technique really helps.
[Erika] Excellent. Thank you. We have somebody who
would love to hear from you about how
the process of imaging your science has
helped shape your thinking about your
research.
[Calvin] I could take this one. So, I
guess, every time I try to think of an
of,
you know, a research project or something,
I try to think about how my project makes sense
in terms of like... or rather, like, what
is the context of the project in the
broader world? So,
every time I do something, I think about
like, why people should care about this
and how I can present these results to
the world and convince people that
they're significant. I think that's
actually a really helpful process
because, as researchers, you know
we like go and read many papers, and then
we say, "oh, well there are like, you know, a
hundred, you know, questions that seem
interesting." But, when you like, sort of,
zoom out for a bit, and think about how
you're going to convey that to the world, I
think it's a really good exercise in
learning how to triage your priorities
because oftentimes we're limited, not by
like what we can do, but will we have the
time and where we best want to
spend our effort doing. So, that's at least one
way that the process of, not just
imaging, but also communicating my ideas
guides where, literally, what I spend
my days doing.
[Sudha] Can I add a few words to what Calvin had
to say? Actually, I completely agree with
him. So, my research actually largely
images things as they're happening. So,
my research relies a lot on basically
evidence gathering, through looking at
pictures, and basically the part and
parcel of the whole
sort of imaging technique is that basis
of accuracy in what you are imaging and
it actually tells you a lot about what
to do next.
So, I often would have like two parts
that I put into a system and then image
how they are coming together to, in fact,
even know what could be the story and
what to do next to even explore this
story further. So, imaging is a very
powerful tool for the scientific process
and it can tell you a lot on day-to-day
basis and this might just generally
involve that. Yeah. So, it can definitely
change your scientific exploration to a
great extent. Yeah. So, basically it is a
very powerful tool and very powerful
influencer in my research areas.
[Erika] We have a question from Rachel. How much
do you think about your photos in the
layout? Do you plan it out? I know Sudha,
you just said you take pictures of
things as they happen, but how about
everybody? Do you plan it out or
do you take a bunch of image and test a
lot of things until you find an image
that works for you?
[Quinton] So, kind of just in my
approach with science, we actually try to
take as many pictures as we can. I'm
looking at biological phenomenon. As Matt
was discussing, there's a lot of noise,
and a lot of background. So, you really
want to try to capture as many events as
you can possibly, really dictating that
phenomenon that you're trying to
describe or observe. But then sometimes,
you have very unique things that pop out
from those mosaic of images that you
take. But generally, in my approach, I try
to take as many different types of
pictures to really capture the
phenomenon that I'm studying.
[Matt] I think, for me, a lot of times, I'm thinking about the
magnification in which I'm taking the
picture. Sometimes, you know, we want to
get really close to individual cell, but
then sometimes, we kind of want to take a
step back and take a larger image, which
might require, like, composite of many
images to be taken. So, and those, for
example, the image I took probably took a
couple hours to be able to acquire. So, I
think a lot of times, I play around with
setting up this kind of like composite
or individual and seeing what looks good.
I do have to say that all my images, I
tend to think about they're going to be
shown or seen as, like, a thumb size. These
are going to be small little panels in, like,
a much larger, data rich, hopefully, figure.
But the idea I... sometimes the higher
magnification is a little easier to show
in a small inset.
[Erika] Great. Anyone else? Okay, so we have a
question from Jodi here. So, obviously,
we're all taking these pictures cause we
love science, and we're doing science, and
how important is the imaging when you're
trying to get new funding or applying
for a new project? What role do those
images play?
[Matt] So, typically, when we are trying to get
new funding, we have to write grants and
grants typically include preliminary
data. I think having a good image
won't necessarily, you know, get you those
dollar bills, but it certainly... The
comments I've gotten from reviewers is
that they would say, "this is really
high-quality preliminary data." I
think part of that lingo is about just
the striking-ness of the images, but
together with a lot more quantification,
and the story as a whole. It's not solely
based on the image, but I think it goes a
long way.
[Erika] Did anyone want to add to that? Great.
[Quinton] Just one, kind of, minor note. Sometimes, I really like the sentiment that seeing is believing.
Right. So, it really just drives your point home. Like, at least the type of work that I demonstrated, really
seeing the nice oriented structures is a
really nice proof of concept to really
drive some of your ideas home. So, if you
can even capture it in, like a schematic,
for example. Just like the imagery and
demonstrating really the validity of
your proposal is really important.
[Erika] Then Sudha, did I see that...
[Sudha] Actually, I
was going to say what Quinton just said that
I totally agree with you. That part of
the scientific imaging is also evidence
gathering. So, an image is also a piece of
really powerful evidence and it can
demonstrate that you are able to
basically capture the process to some
extent, for which you're asking money
already. So, it's also a piece of
evidence and seeing is believing. So, yeah,
it helps.
[Erika] Terrific. All right, we have a few more questions
here, but what I want to do is actually
move on to look at some of the images
that were taken through "Imaging Science."
So if... and we'll have some time for Q&A
after, as well. So, we've asked every one
of these five fabulous people to pick an
image out of the gorgeous array that was
submitted. Some of you saw those in the
opening slide show, but we've asked
everybody to pick an image and we're
going to just have a conversation about
some of the images that stood out to
people and what they liked about them.
We're going to mix up the order this
time, I think. Calvin, why don't we start
with you?
[Calvin] Sounds good. Thanks, Erika. So, I
really like this photo of a pot of water
on a stove. It actually really stood
out to me, not because the subject was
particularly unusual (like, everyone boils
a pot of water every day), but I think
this is really indicative of the
scientific process in physics and
astronomy, where a lot of the times there
are processes that you want to observe
and you don't have direct access to that.
So, if you want to see fire, you look at
the pot of boiling water that's on top
of it. I think that's really the image
here, right? You don't... like, we all,
intuitively, can make that scientific
leap. You know, even without seeing the
flames, or without feeling the heat, you
look at this pot of water, you look at
the way that bubbles are formed -- these
are very different from soap bubbles -- and
you already know that there's
a phase transition between
the liquid and the gas phases of the
water. That's probably caused by
convection from below and there's a heat
source underneath that, and that's why we
include that at
the bottom of this pot there is a gas fire making these
bubbles. So, you know, we prove the
existence of fire every day just by
looking at this image and I think that's
pretty cool.
[Erika] I love that -- the story within the story.
Do any of our other presenters
want to comment on this photo or what
Calvin said? Not everybody has seen each
of the photos that everyone's picked.
[Lina] Yeah, I really loved this photo, as well.
I'm so glad you picked it, Calvin.
For me, what was really striking is
when you first look at it, you're like,
"What is it?" and then, you know, you take a
couple seconds, and you're like, "Oh yeah,
this is boiling water." For me, that
you know, that instant of, like, some
really interesting visual that makes you
pause and say, "what am I looking at?"
Like that instant, especially in a
science photograph, is that opportunity
to teach and learn, right? Because then
someone's going to look at the title, or
caption, and learn something and this,
Calvin has expanded upon ,it's an
opportunity to teach, you know, about
phase shifts or,
you know, different phases of water and
boiling. Whatever the direction the
photographer wants to take the teaching
in, this photograph is just an invitation for that.
[Erika] Alright, well now
we're cooking. Sounds good. I think
Quinton, I think you're up next then.
[Quinton] So, I
might be a little biased in this picture.
I'm from New Mexico, so immediately the
cacti spikes, like, came out to me. But,
what I really enjoy about this picture,
is just that the complexity in terms of
the organization in the architecture. So,
you see a lot of order, you see the
spikes in a very particular manner. And
with the image across the purple
backdrop, it really highlights the
different cacti. So, I
really enjoyed this image, not only from
me kind of being a little homesick and
reminding me of New Mexico, but also
being able to capture the different
architectures within them.
[Matt] I just
wanted to add that there's so many
beautiful images of nature. It seemed
that a lot of people are very inspired
by being outdoors and I think, especially
when we're experiencing a lot of, you
know, being locked up, but I agree this is
great.
[Erika] Yes. One thing that I didn't have
time to talk about in the opening
webinar... and I'm going to, kind of, jump in
and hijack this a little bit and talk
about my own graduate work in
understanding how people make sense of
images. What I did with my graduate
work, is I looked at how people make
sense of science imagery using an arts
education framework. So, one of the
frameworks I used was the Tate Modern's,
"Ways of Looking," which says that we look
at images in a variety of ways, and
artwork in a variety of ways, and the
first thing we do is find that personal
connection and I heard that from
Quinton there. Then after that, we
want to know, we want to look at the
subject and say, "Well, what is this a
picture of? What's going on here?
What's happening?" Which is, of course, a
key element of science. But then, even
beyond that, people want to look at the
object, at the photograph, or the artwork,
or the composition as something that
was deliberately created. What did you
use to take this?
Why did you choose these colors? What's
going on?  What are the physical
properties of the image itself? Then,
the fourth way of looking, is just
looking at this wider context. Why did we
take this image? What was going on in the
world when this photograph was taken?
I think that's something that really
comes out in all of these photos.
All right. Lina, would you like to share an image with us?
[Lina] Sure, let me share my
screen. All right, so, I've touched on this
before, but what I really love about
photographs, and especially science
photographs, is a photo that makes you
pause for some reason. It could be, like,
that it's just a beautiful image, it
could be that you kind of do a
double-take, you're like, "What am I looking
at?" And then, once you have that hook, that
someone's paused in the midst of their
busy day, that's an opportunity to go and
teach something. The reason I love
this photo... and I guess I'll say, before
I dive into this one in
particular, there were so many
fantastic photos. Anyone who submitted a
photo should be incredibly proud. There
were so many really good ones.
I ultimately picked this one, a) because I
thought it was so beautiful. The colors
are stunning, the composition is stunning.
It's this really ethereal quality of a
photo and then, so it just made me pause.
Again, then that's an opportunity to
go and teach something. So, I feel like
that once you have someone's attention
here, it's an opportunity to teach about
surface tension, or ripple patterns, and
wave formations, and equations for the,
you know, crest and trough of waves. So,
there's a lot that, kind of, can be taught
once you have that person's attention.
[Sudha] So,
one thing that I really like about this
image is that it freezes the motion,
which is a very hard thing to do
technically, and also it's very beautiful
to look at. So, it's like a drop that's
basically is frozen in time and those
images are actually very powerful because
they're telling the story in time, but in
one frame. So, it's a beautifully captured
phenomena. I think
that's the, sort of, very nice feature of this
image that I really like.
[Erika] Alright, Calvin ,why
don't you go ahead now.
[Calvin] One neat detail I notice, is that you'll notice that around the droplet, there are these two rings of
water propagating outwards. The fact
that the outer ring is much
more smeared out than the inner one,
tells you that the speed of surface
waves on this water is different for
different wavelengths. So,
that's a pretty non-trivial thing to notice just
in this picture. There's a lot of very
interesting detail captured here.
[Erika] Terrific. Thanks. Yes, I love the capturing
of time and space in these things.
Both of those things are essential for running a science experiment or
what's happening in our world. Time and
space matter. All right.
But Matt, let's see your choice.
[Matt] I take the field, but this one really
spoke to me because I have this motto in
lab that everything is data. So, I carry
my iPhone with me everywhere and iPhone
cameras are so good nowadays that I, kind
of, do this a lot where I put my camera
onto the ocular of the microscope. So,
you end up getting this kind of ring,
which is the ocular, but then you get the
image through. I typically will crop
it, you know, and just use the image
inside. But, I love the fact that this
tells a very clear message, at least to
me as a scientist, of where that
photographer was. I feel like I
understand the process. I'm seeing it
as a person saw it. You know, there
were a series of images
posted with the same kind of photograph
from a microscope with just different
maybe substrates being imaged. But, I
think that when you can capture the
process in the image, I think that could
be really powerful too. So, this is kind
of what spoke to me about the series of
phone to the ocular images.
[Sudha] I have a comment on that. It's a great choice, Matt. I also like the part that the texture of
the subject is so nicely visible in the
image, which is not usually the case.
Normally, there's a compromise between contrast
and texture and here that doesn't seem to
be the case. So, it's really commendable
effort on technicality and it's a really great image.
[Erika] Yeah, I think that
comparison can be really powerful in an
image. One of the things we talked about
with Keith and Felice, is making the
decision of what to photograph, and what
not to photograph. And what you show is
often dependent on what you don't show,
or the choices you make of how you
compare things. Absolutely. Alright,
Sudha, is your is your image ready to go? There it is.
[Sudha] So, apologies for the
interruption. I like this image
because, like Lina was saying, that an
interesting aspect to the image is that it
may... if it will incite you to stop and
pause for a moment and think a little
bit about the image. Maybe the process of
how it was taken, the story around it, and
also a message that is coming through.
I felt that this image was combining
a lot of different things and these
different things are nicely. So, first of
all, the composition is really nice. The
objects, the rice grains, are nicely placed.
Even though they aren't
brilliant in color, the colors are very
nice and overall composition is very,
very nice. What I also liked about is also
my personal bias as a microscopy person.
So, I like to see small things seen in
better details to see things that we
can't generally see with the naked eye,
or ordinarily. So, to see beyond what our
eye can see. So, for example, if I
hold a rice grain, I wouldn't know that it's
actually asymmetrical. So, then one side
is more shaded than the other side.
So, there's asymmetry I didn't know
existed. Then, what is this dark color?
Is it where the embryo used to sit or
the fertile part of the rice grain?
Which, again, I didn't know existed
in a processed rice like this. So, it's
like a collection of scientific
messages that are encompassed in this
image. So, that part I really liked. I
also liked the technical mystery around it.
So, I really want to know how it was
taken. There seems to be some back
illumination happening,
but I'm not sure. So, it seems like the
person who took the image had a good sense of
technicality of how to illuminate the grains to get the most information out.
So, I really like that part. Yeah, so
basically, it's a combination of the
composition, the visualization beyond
what we ordinarily see, and also the
trick that has been used here. That's why
I really like this image.
[Erika] Thank you. Would any of the other
panelists like to comment on this image?
[Calvin] Yeah, I was going to ask what the little dark
flecks are. There are these big, dark
spots, as you said. I think those are the embryos
of the rice grain. But, there are also
sort of these dark flecks and I don't.. do
you have any idea what those are or are
those just, like, imperfections?
I know nothing about plants so...
[Sudha] Same here. I don't have here what I can see the...
it's an interesting question. Maybe the
participant could comment on it later or
any of you know about it. I don't know. It
adds nice features to the grains, but
I'm not sure.
[Erika] If I'm not mistaken, this image was posted on social media, which means it's there on the hashtag and
perhaps that's a nice conversation to
begin online. I love this idea of... we
didn't really talk about this, but it was
so important -- that a good image provokes
questions. In some cases, we've seen
those, or questions about the details of
what's being photographed, about the
wider context and phenomenon that's
behind it. Looking for things we can't
see. You know, like, clearly you all
are scientists because you've got
questions about these and the photos
both answer them and ask them, as well,
and I think that's really powerful.
[Matt] I was just going to jump in to say that one of
our attendees, Dora Bever, is telling us
these are the germs, of the germ of
the rice, and this is the part that
will become the plant. So, maybe this is
her image or she's a rice enthusiast.
[Erika] Yes, I think this is Dora's image. Excellent. I
can't see the chat. I'm making sure
my microphone is on and off. But, I can
see the clock and I see that we are
almost at two o'clock and I think
all of us could go on and on and talk
about what we love about images. There
are a couple questions about what you
use to take your photos, what tools
you like for photography. Do you use your
camera, phone? If you wanted to type in
answers to that while Brian talks
a little bit more about where we want to
go from here. This was a two-week
experiment with "Imaging Science."
Before I turn it over to Brian, I do want
to thank all of our researchers. Thank
you so much for taking time out of your
Saturday afternoons, or mornings, for
those of you in California, to share your
images, your perspectives.
I love the conversation that we had and
the different perspectives on, both the
research images, and the MIT "Imaging
Science" images. I'm so grateful for
all of you for joining in. The last
question is, you know, "What are the
opportunities for students who want to
continue pursuing imaging science?" So,
for that, we're obviously going to leave
this content online, but I think I'll
bring Brian back to kind of answer the
questions about where things are
going from here.
[Brian] Thank you, Erica. Thank you, everyone, all of our panelists for joining us today, and thank you to all
the participants out there who have
submitted some really incredible photos.
I think you did exactly what we were
hoping, which was get out there, go around
your homes, go outside and take some cool
images, make some observations of things
that you hadn't before through
photography.
So, this is our closing webinar for this
section of "Imaging Science." But, please
keep a lookout for more programming
under the title "Imaging Science" or under
the hashtag #MITMImagingScience
because we definitely like to continue
doing things with imaging, and imaging
science photography, and science into the
future. So, we're going to sign off now, but
I'm going to throw up the slideshow of
many of the images that have been
submitted throughout the two weeks. So,
feel free to hang on for a few minutes
and enjoy those images as they come in.
[Erika] Yeah, thank you to everyone who submitted
images and thank you again to our
panelists for helping us appreciate
what makes great science photos.
[Calvin] Thanks, Erica and Brian for putting everything
together.
[Erika] I'm sticking around because I'm excited to see all these images because I told myself I was going
to be surprised [clap] when they came on the
slideshow, but thank you everybody.
[Silence]